what's up logan how are you doing hey
john hey rachel how you guys doing
good good good what's up um so a little
debate here between my fiance and i
oh you're going to drag us into it huh
don't be the typewriter
absolutely so we're getting married uh
on may 30th so coming up pretty soon um
and we recently started fpu um we're
feeling pretty good about it pretty
gazelle intense between the two of us
right now we're working
seven jobs and in two weeks went from 11
grand in debt to
2 800. so way to go man
yeah thank you um so
and i know this is a little farther down
the line but one of our goals um
is to purchase a house uh with cash
um within the next 10 years or so um
however i was thinking about it and i
think so what she wants to do is just
save up after we get done with baby step
three go into uh 3b
and save up specifically for the house
however i think
because of how young we are i think it
will be more beneficial to use that time
to open up
roth ira i'm going to max that out at 6
000
every year and then what's left over
after investing into that
um put into either a money market or a
mutual fund to save for a large down
payment on the house
um because we're right now i'm 19 and
she's 20.
um so the yield on that would be a lot
bigger if we start earlier sure so the
debate is
save up and pay cash right away for the
house or not right away it'll take years
to save obviously
or go ahead and take out a mortgage and
continue on is that that's the debate
right
save up and pay cash well no either
either way we wouldn't be
we'd be purchasing the house at the same
time it would just be
do we want to spend these 9 10 years
before we buy
just saving for the house or should we
invest
into retirement and then what's left
over after investing every year put that
into a savings for a large down payment
on the house
but you're saying down payment when you
put a down payment you're taking out a
mortgage though so it's not cash
right right right i'm sorry not not not
i thought you were saying
by now but okay
let me let me make sure i'm
understanding this i'm sorry i
so do you take let's say there's a
hundred thousand dollars do you take 50
of that and start investing it now
do you have a hundred thousand dollars
though logan like i'm not making that up
yes but i'm saying but once you get once
you guys pay off your debt
you're going to save up for that
emergency fund three to six months worth
of expenses
then what we would suggest that you do
if you want to buy a home
then is to save up baby step 3b for a 10
to 20
down payment and then start investing i
would not use baby step 3b
to save cash and not invest in a roth
ira so i'm more on your side on it
i would i would go ahead and keep
putting money away now if you want to
use
it would be baby step thr right baby
step four is investing
and if you wanted to say hey we want to
rent for six years
and we're gonna save up and write a
check for a house in six years
while we invest you can totally do that
i think that that's a great idea but i
would not miss
out on the investing to save up to pay
cash for a house
does that answer your question okay yes
yeah
i i wouldn't because because like you
said you guys are you guys are young
you have the time a mortgage is the one
type of debt we won't yell at you for so
if you did decide hey we are going to
just do a down payment of 20
go ahead and do the 15-year fixed rate
do the formula to buy a house the right
way
that's great you can do that but if you
guys were kind of
more on the quote-unquote weird side
which we like weird people and say hey
you know we're going to run a small
apartment
we're going to live on nothing and we
for for eight years we can save up x
amount and pay cash for a house but
we're gonna do that
that's awesome and you've never had a
mortgage in your entire life that would
be that would be great too okay
so either either one of those is totally
is as great
from our book yeah does that answer your
question i'm sorry i know that was a
long way around but
okay no that's fine it does yeah thank
you and logan
um not to oversimplify this but you're
19 she's
20 y'all feel like you're 100 years old
right now
and then when you turn 30 you're gonna
feel like man we're really young right
now right
and so it feels like you if you mess
this decision up
it's man you might as well you're not
going to start over your marriage is
going to be off to a sideways start
you all are so far ahead of the average
couple getting ready to get married
yes you you just need to stop and pause
for a second y'all are crushing you're
going to get married in a few months
you're going to be off to the races
and go slow do it together right then
and rachel's right
when you when you're 30 you're gonna
love that you have a retirement account
that you started when you were 20 21
years old
you're also going to love you got a big
chunk of a down payment or
y'all went ahead and rented for a few
more years and just started your whole
new family tree with no mortgage at all
that's right that's going to be awesome